so many times women say let me break
these barriers and let me come into
these industries but we're not talented
or strong enough to actually break those
barriers you know if a woman is actually
as strong and as physically capable as a
man I have no problem with her being in
the police but when we start lowering
standards to allow women to be in
industries that they do not deserve that
is when I have a problem and in my
opinion you are going to find very few
women that actually have what it takes
to be a good police officer sir and by
the way this is not just for women I
feel the same way about overweight
police officers yes get in shape sir I I
need you to we need you to run after the
criminals not die of diabetes you know
what I'm saying and